I'm Alexa. Nice to meet you. Just
like animals. I get that so often.
Alexa? Yeah, like Amazon or you got it.
I'm just glad it's like that
thing I can be like, Yo Alexa,
maybe this song.
Yeah,
I'm nervous if I'm being honest.
Do you feel like you'll know the person
even if you can't see them today?
I feel like I will.
Yes.
I'm pretty good about picking
up inflections of like
voices and everything and I
can tell somebody who's being honest
with me or not by their voice,
so I feel like I'll do
really well with that.
Everyone who's not sitting play some
music. Kind of do your own thing.
Hi.
Hello. What's your name? I'm going
to go. What's your name? I'm Alexa.
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you. That's
a really cute name though. Oh, thank you.
How old are you? I'm 18 how
old are you? I'm 23 okay.
Do you have any goals in the future?
Ah, yes. One of my biggest
goals right now as to uh,
be able to have enough money to buy my mom
her own house. I would love that. My
name is Alexa. Oh, it was my mom's name.
Really? No, not really.
Oh, are you in school? Yes,
I'm studying to either be
a marine biologist or a
psychologist. Where do you go?
Oh, I go to bio lab. It's
a Christian college. That's
cool. So you're a Christian?
Yes, very much so. Or just a
little bit. Ah, very much so.
So are you like working or are you going
to school or something like that? I'm,
I'm working on getting
work. Yeah, I'm broke.
So tell me a little about yourself.
What do you, what do you do right now?
I'm a full time student. Okay. I
love all of the arts. So painting,
photography, stuff like
that. How about you?
I uh, I'm actually really into
airplanes. Um, I'd say photography.
I do a little bit of camera
shoots and stuff like that.
So I guess we have something in common.
There was good.
Hi,
my name is Tyler. I'm going to
ask you a question really quick.
This is really important.
If we went to yogurt land,
would you put chocolate
on new yogurt or fruit?
Cause that's like really important
to me. I felt both. Okay.
You're already a freak. I can tell. This
is crazy. How are you? Um, awesome. Yeah,
I can tell your voice. You sound
like really energetic. Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm super outgoing and everything.
Oh goodness gracious.
Yeah.
I'm going to have to get rid of JV because
I just didn't feel like a connection
there with the one after.
Caleb also just didn't really feel
like a straight connection there.
I'd say my ideal date would be,
I don't want to be too cliche,
but long walks on the beach.
But also I always wanted to go on a Ferris
wheel with one beautiful girl. Okay.
Mine would be probably driving
around and Pauli and up on the beach.
Pretend to know about
constellations and stuff.
So I'm going to tell you straight
off the bat like I suck at planning.
Do you know like those
retro like diamonds? Yes.
Like with the colors and
the lights and stuff.
I think that'd be a really good
location. Cute. Okay. All right. So,
so bear with me half,
but a lot of thought into this.
So I'm working on getting my pilot's
license. I'm thinking you and me, we go,
we go, we hop into a little private
plane at the airport. Right? We take it,
we fly up the coast of
California and you know,
there's little islands off the coast,
right?
We could go and kind of fly over
to one of the little islands.
Obviously you're into photography. You
bring your camera and get some nice shots.
We definitely need to share memes with
each other because my main game is crazy.
So like if you don't have good
tastes in means we can't be a thing.
Like this is not going to work. Oh
trust me, I have an entire folder.
Might have to go buy a ring or
something. I don't know. Laughter.
I think laughter is really,
really cool.
I like to do like impressions and stuff
like that. So uh, like black pants.
Oh my gosh,
what is your name?
All right. So, um, I'm going to have
to get rid of, let's see, Miguel,
initially I felt kind of a connection,
but after that I just kind of,
it kind of went away a little bit.
And then whoever the third person was,
and it's because initially he just
immediately said he was bad at planning.
And I like someone who's really good at
planning and stuff like that because I
love being creative and
all that kind of stuff. So
I think for me personally,
if someone's not vocal,
if you're on a date or
whatever, explaining who you
really are, how you feel.
It goes. Very foreign in a relationship.
I would say most of the time Christian,
like, you know, excessive
drinking or like smoking,
like a little bit's fine, but
like if it's excess, yeah,
a little bit hard to smoking
and drinking thing, you know?
I wouldn't want to date someone who's,
he's a partier, you know, every weekend.
That's just not really my scene.
What's Gucci man?
I feel like I need someone who can like
twerk, you know? Like that's what I want.
I want.
So even if you can't do it that well,
I want you to try it on
someone who can have fun.
I want to continue from where we last off.
What would you say is like a,
a really big talent of yours?
I guess I can sing, but like I'm
not very confident with it. Okay.
I mean, I'm not like horrible, but I
don't really been public about it I guess.
Look you up.
Um, okay. First one's
going to have to be Tyler.
He was talking about
twerking and everything.
I haven't tried it so I
don't know if I can do it,
but he also didn't seem like he was
very serious about our relationship.
And then I'm going to have to,
uh, Caleb, no particular reason.
Just wasn't really feeling it anymore.
I guess
I want to be able to say
that I can own a house,
but hopefully by the time I'm
30, you know, have my family set.
How many kids do you want? Hopefully
by like a boy and a girl to be honest.
And then maybe like three or four dogs.
So yeah,
I'm very slowly with that. Oh, nice.
And I want the boy to be a
little older than the girl. See,
I want it the other way around so the
girl can believe the boring for me.
Something that's really important.
I'm trying to become a pilot and I,
I've joined the navy to try and achieve
that goal and I'm still working there.
And that's something I
feel like for my partner,
I want them to be the same
mentality that I'm in.
You can't be in a relationship with
one person is motivated. Right.
And the other person is, it doesn't
really care. I've got a lot,
so I'm a musician actor,
but I'm also studying political science
and I want to be president of the United
States. So obviously, um, you know,
being with somebody that's like committed
but also like supportive and I can
learn a lot from them, um, that, that
really means a lot to me. What about you?
I'm leaning towards psychologists so I
can help teens with mental disorders and
everything like that.
There's a lot of, I think,
genuine connection and you really
like care about people, you know,
because then you can look beyond where
they are and like see them for who they
truly can be. And I think
that's super special. Yeah,
I'm kidding one.
Okay.
Um,
I'm just going to have to cut off Sam.
The vibe that I'm getting just isn't as
strong as the other two that I've been
getting.
Okay.
So no prompt here.
So I want to know a little bit about you.
Tell me about yourself. What
are your hobbies? I like to
dance. Um, wait, wait, wait,
stop there. Stop there. Dance.
Are we talking like salsa or break dance
in here because I'm okay with both.
More so hip hop than anything. Okay,
that's cool. What else do you like?
So you like dance, you like to sing? I
was thinking on my way here to every song.
That's awesome. That's cool.
But what about photography?
I'm kind of curious about that. Do you
like portraits? Landscapes? My main focus,
I guess you could say his portrait.
Um, I love shooting animals as well.
Like wildlife. Yeah. You love
taking a photo on me though.
So what's the hardest thing that you've
ever been through and how did you get
through it and how did it affect
who you are uniquely today?
One of the hardest things I've had to
go through was probably middle school.
Beginning of high school
because I struggled with a
lot of depression and self
confidence. Um, I've overcame it by
like, I'm starting to love myself,
I'm super outgoing and I help people.
So helping people helps me. Yeah. Yeah.
That's amazing.
Why would definitely say like you have
to embrace who you are because it's
unique and what you bring to the world
is different than any other person in the
other individual. And it makes
you, you are today, you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
I think I have a decision.
All right,
so I'm going to have to go with Joseph.
That last question that he asked me.
It shows me that he can actually get
really deep when he needs to be and that's
the kind of stuff that I'm looking for.
Like I want someone who I
can have a ton of fun with,
but I can also be super serious
with when the time comes.
So that kind of set it over the bar
and that's what I'm looking for. So
thank
you.
I'm definitely more used to like talking
to people like face to face and being
more real. So, so a weird
in a nutshell. Yeah.
As we,
this is all about
Yo. Nice. Nice to meet you. How are you?
I'm good. How are you
doing well, I'm doing well.
I didn't really envision you looking like
anything but I'm really happy or cute.
Thank you. Thank you. Yeah,
I know this kind of go somewhere I guess.
Well I got a girl.
What?
I'm really good. You're awesome though.
Like did this just happen? Dang. Okay
girlfriend. I do. Do I just show up?
I'm the only one that doesn't go here.
Why are you guys here? As for
single people? Yeah. Oh Dad.
I told my girlfriend like all about it
and everything and she said it sounds
like a cool,
oh cool.
Okay.
I thought it was like a prank
on me. I was like okay, like,
and then everyone else was as surprised
as me and I was like guest not,
that is weird cause I totally went into
this thinking that I was going to end up
with somebody who is
single and like looking,
but I mean I'm not hurt or anything.
I'm just kinda confused as to
why he was here. But I mean,
it's whatever. I'm happy he
has a girlfriend, I guess,
cause he's,
he's actually a genuinely like really
cool person and he had everything that I
was looking for, so he must've had
everything that she was looking for.
So I hope that they're
happy and everything.
Yeah.